chad cool
take it as his responsibility to help
you enjoy the game
and he does
let her rip
tucker kind of with an awkward start i
don't know if he lost his footing but he
got the out and that's all that matters
tucker maybe started a step back and to
break
to his right cj antone gets the start
for the reds this afternoon in
pittsburgh and eric gonzalez three hit
day yesterday
goodwin
can't get there
and gonzalez reading that all the way
he's at second base love that hustle
a little flare off the end of the bat
hopeful that it can find the grass
antone going to work here against
polanco
swing and a miss first strikeout of the
afternoon for t.j antone
galvis in his first played appearance of
the series strikes out for strikeout for
chad cool
and
safe at second
ryan goodwin with a pair of steals the
other day and his third as a red already
the two outs
farmer frozen on a high breaking ball
there's a good one
and he strikes him out so cool with
three strikeouts after the walk
ground ball could be two farmer galvest
mustaches that's a double play leadoff
man on for cincinnati the castiano's
foul the plate
one oh to costianos
center field hit well nick costa yonos
out of here
two run home run
and the red strike first again
you said it the other day cowboy he
starts getting those extra bass hits and
they all of a sudden come in bunches you
get him going with gino going and
mustaches are starting to swing the bat
a little bit better
you hit a solo home run or do you get
three singles
so suarez down on strikes here's
mustaches
high fly ball
to the wall is polanco leaping up
and it's off the wall
mustache will hold up at second base
and it's a two-out double for moose
he's ahead on brian goodwin
he win
james hoy says strikeout
that man
quite a bit of comfortability knowing
he's up 2-0 you don't have to be so
perfect gives him some great freedom and
then he goes out and gets right on the
attack and that's what that allows you
to do those extra couple runs
strike three called the hook that's just
a paralyzer
back to back strikeouts for anto
two out man in scoring position reynolds
account of one and two
out towards center falling fast and
that's gonna bring in frazier
brian reynolds comes through and he's
gonna take second base he never stopped
and once cassalli had a hard time with
it he'll get into scoring position nice
aggressive base running and a nice hit
for reynolds and tone deals and it's a
fastball up and in swung out and missed
down on strikes gregory polanco three
strikeouts in the inning for
t.j antone
back to anton could be two farmer
double play nicely done nine one and two
for the pirates here in the fifth
swing and a miss filthy definitely got a
strikeout pitch in that slider of his
and he's got a good hard fastball
just nasty stuff back to back strikeouts
for antone 1-0 pitch
how about t.j antone
five innings of one run baseball tying
run now in scoring position
go ahead run at first base
looks like the reds will call on rysella
glacious for a multi-inning save
0-2 pitch
swaying and a miss
good morning good afternoon good night
and now and out away from getting out of
damage batter gregory polanco
fastball
center field will
back up akiyama he's got it and the
inning is over
josh bell can tie the game with one
swing of the bat here against raiso
iglesias
there's a base hit ty runs out
what good hands there from josh bell
who've been talking about it looks like
he's been tracking the ball pretty good
key brian hayes has hit the ball
hard twice today to that first week
well he's going to find himself a board
running the base hit and that'll work
bells thinking third yeah put on the
brakes
keep ryan hayes with his second hit
and he pushes the tying around into
scoring position and now the winning run
is on see how the pirates play this now
is it bunt time for cole tucker guides
one of the right side and through
bell's gonna be waved home here comes
castiano's throw
it's late and bell is in tucker will
scramble to second the pirates have tied
it in the knife
good job cole tucker
battling
with two strikes
and finding a hole
ground ball back to iglesias they've got
the runner caught up
casalli after keep ryan hayes and he'll
tag him out and still second and third
with one out eric gonzalez trying for
his first ever walk-off hit
sending it out to right
here comes tucker
offline throw in the bucks with it
eric gonzalez
drives in the game-winner
the buck's only lead
is the only one they need i guess
they're going to postpone the
celebration until they review it
let's look at them sink them there's
akiyama on the left
[Music]
i can see why the reds wanted to look at
it because he had to go back but he's
fine safe
yes sir
and now the celebration can't begin in
earnest